As part of this class you're going to
have to write some software.
In particular, you're going to have to
write some machine learning algorithms.
It's useful if we standardize on
what the application programmer
interface ought to look like for
the code you're going to write.
So here's what it looks like.
For a linear regression
learning algorithm,
your API ought to implement
something that works like this.
A constructor that creates
an instance of one of these learners,
which is now learner.
A method called train that can take
our training data and train the model.
And a query function that takes a list
of X values that you want to test and
returns a list of Y values according to
what the model thinks they should be.
These Y values, in turn, are the ones
that we'll compare to Y test
to see how well the algorithm works.
Our KNNLearner ought to
have the same methods.
The only difference is the constructor
here has this additional argument, K,
which would allow you to set
how large you want K to be.
So if K is 3, that means you
use the 3 nearest neighbors.
But it also has a train and a query
function, just like linear regression.